Polonia se convirtió en el primer
miembro de la otan que proporciona
aviones de combate a Ucrania mientras
continúa defendiéndose de las tropas del
kremlin el jueves el presidente andrey
duda dijo que Varsovia proporcionará
alrededor de una docena de aviones de
combate mig 29 de La Era soviética para
reforzar a Ucrania en la guerra el
primer envío entrará en servicio de
manera inminente
estos jets están en sus últimos años de
servicio de acuerdo con sus
posibilidades técnicas pero en la
mayoría de los casos todavía están en
buenas condiciones de funcionamiento en
los próximos días entregaremos cuatro
aviones a Ucrania todos en perfectas
condiciones de funcionamiento los otros
aviones están siendo revisados y
preparados para ser entregados
gradualmente
con la guerra al otro lado de su
frontera Polonia ha asumido un papel
central en la movilización del
suministro occidental de armas a Ucrania
pero la entrega de casas de fabricación
rusa es un gran paso sin necesidad de
entrenamiento adicional para los pilotos
ucranianos es probable que los cazas de
la era soviética se pongan en uso
durante meses el presidente ha estado
pidiendo un mayor poder aéreo para
defender los cielos de su país pero su
gobierno está pidiendo que se suministre
en casas f-16 más modernos
los micros no resolverán las tareas
necesitamos f-16 pero los mix sí
ayudarán a fortalecer nuestras
capacidades
El guardián de las llaves de esos f-16
es Estados Unidos pero hasta ahora
Washington ha resistido la presión para
entregar cualquier avión incluso a la
luz de la decisión de Polonia sin
embargo otros países pronto podrían
seguir su ejemplo hay rumores de que
otras naciones han acordado enviar casas
de Última Generación como parte de un
acuerdo de coalición más amplio y las
fuentes sugieren que Eslovaquia podría
ser el próximo en enviar sus aviones un
movimiento que el Antiguo estado
satélite soviético había sugerido en el
pasado